[Music]  it's so much worse than I thought  they'll drive the Nazis out of Paris  just like daddy did back home no phone  calls no letters he just vanished  my agents inform me that he left the  country under a false identity about  four weeks ago  [Music]  codenamed Blackbird Paris catacombs bats  your leave he's in Paris you know if we  say something they are gonna do get [ __ ]  well I guess it's just up to us then  let me show you something  it's do or die just like daddy told us  [Music]  [Music]  yeah you guys are weird but BJ [ __ ]  blaskowitz doesn't want to be found  no one on God's green earth that's gonna  find his ass we got this [ __ ] is [ __ ]  a  have you ever killed Nazis before we  were born to kill not  [Music]  [Music]